موضوعنا التالي مختلف لانه سنتحدث عن
الفاكهه ولكن ليس اي فاكهه الفاكهه
الملكيه المانجو صباح المانجو
يعني من وين ابدا
انا احب جازان احب المانجا احب الاجواء
اتذكر لانه انا قعدت فتره طويله في جازان
في هذه البلد
الجميله صبيه ابو عريش وبقيه المناطق هذه
الخارطه هذه اللي
تغيرت بانتاجيه جازان للمانجو وصل عدد
اشجار المانجو في في جازان هذا العام الى
مليون شجره تنتج اكثر من 65
الف عدد مهول طبعا موسم انتاج المانجو
مشاهدينا في جيزان يبلغ
وتو
حيث تذكر اسواق جازان هذه الايام بفاك
هاتها الاستوائيه وصولا الى مهرجان
المانجو هذا المهرجان اصبح احد المحطات
العالميه للمانجو لانه يسوق لعلامه تجاريه
مميزه
وليست مانجو عاديه لا ابدا طبعا قبل
الاحتفاء بالمانجو مشاهدينا لهذه الفاكهه
فوائد صحيه مفاجئه راح تستغربوا ذلك بحسب
دراسه حديثه وتخيلوا مفيده كمان للمصابين
بالسمنه مع انها
حلوه مثل السكري يعني البعض بالاضافه الى
طعمها هناك فوائد روحي يا لميس هاتي ما
لديك فوائد اكثر من كنتم بتتخيلوا هلا راح
اقول لكم
في دراسه حديثه تم اجراؤها في جامعه
الامريكيه تبين ان استهلاك المانجو له
تاثير ايجابي على الاشخاص الذين يعانون من
مرض التهاب الامعاء نتائج الدراسه اظهرت
ان استهلاك المانجو الطازج يعد مساعدا
هاما وله دور كبير في العلاج التقليدي
للحالات التي تعاني من التهاب الامعاء
خصوصا في الحالات الخفيفه والمعتدله وذلك
بسبب احتوائها على مضادات الاكسده التي
تحد من امراض الامعاء الالتهابيه المانجو
ايضا تعز الهضم من خلال احتوائها على
مجموعه من الان زيمات الهاضمه التي تقوم
بتحطيم جزيئات الطعام الكبيره ليسهل
امتصاصها وتجزا الكربوهيدرات المعقده تعزز
المانجو صحه القلب وذلك بفضل احتوائها على
كل من الالياف والفيتامينات والبوتاسيوم
التي تعمل على تحسين عمل الشرايين وتقلل
خطر الاصابه بامراض القلب وكل ذلك يصب في
مصلحه المصابين بالسمنه
[موسيقى]
من جازان ينضم الينا مراسل صباح العربيه
اسامه القاسم اسامه صباح الخير صباح
المانجا قولي ابو عريش ولا صبيه ولا وين
الاكثر انتاجيه وشو اللي يغير ايش اللي
يميز المانجا السعوديه
اهلا وسهلا عادل اهلا وسهلا راويه تحيه
طيبه لكم اول لجميع المشاهدين صباح
العربيه انقل لكم الصوت والصور اليوم من
هنا من مزرعه فال احدى اكبر مزارع الشرق
الاوسط في زراعه المانغو اكبر مزرعه
لزراعه المانجو في السعوديه طبعا هنا
نتحدث اليوم عن اعداد هائله جدا من
الاصناف المتواجده اليوم في مهرجان
المانجو التي تنتجها مزارع جازان باكثر من
60 صنفا هناك مفارقه عادل وراويه ساتحدث
عنها الان ان عام 2005 شهدت منطقه جازان
اكثر من 250 الف شجره في حوالي خمسه الاف
مزرعه بما يزيد عن
18,000 طن اليوم نتحدث عن اكثر من مليون
شجره باكثر من تسعه عشر الاف مزرعه في
انتاج يصل الى 65 الف طن سنويا من المانجو
باكثر من 60 سم اكثر الاصناف الموجوده
اليوم وهي الاكثر شعبيه من خلال الاستهلاك
وايضا البيع والتصدير هي اللانجرا وايضا
وايضا التومي نتحدث الان واترك لكم الصوت
والصوره الان في هذه المنطقه اكبر مزارع
السعوديه في زراعه المانجو كما اسبقت
نتحدث اليوم عن فوائد المانجو ايضا ماذا
ميز جازان لتكون هي سله غذاء السعوديه ومن
اهم الفواكه والمنتجات التي تصدرها جازان
للسعوديه وخارج السعوديه
المانجو اولا تعرف بالجازان بانها بيئه
خصبه من ناحيه التربه التربه هنا تربه
رطبه جدا وايضا الامطار في هذه الفتره
بالذات تكون امطار على شكل متواتره نتحدث
اليوم ايضا على ان هذه الاشجار التي
تشاهدونها الان تغذى من خلال المياه
الجوفيه في باطن الارض التي تجعل هذه
الاشجار باخضرار دائم بالرغم من اعتدال
الجو حتى حرارته في بعض الاحيان نتحدث
اليوم اذا عن هذه الاعداد الكبيره جدا
اكثر من 60 صنف باكثر من 65 الف طن يتم
تصديرها سنويا يعني الاشجار محمله بثمرات
المانجو الحقيقه يعني انا ما كنتش محظوظه
مثل عادل اني ازور جازان واني اجرب
المانجا السعوديه بدي وعد منك يا اسامه
تبعث لي اياهم شكرا شكرا جزيلا مراسل
العربيه
اتحدث اليوم
فجوه القصص الانسانيه وال
وثائق تقارير
تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات